well I believe our dependency on OPEC
oil is a major problem we have
legislation pending now in the Senate I
introduced along with Senator Kohl a
provision to take away the antitrust
exemption which OPEC Saudi Arabia
Venezuela and the other OPEC nations
have they sit down in the room or reduce
supply and the prices go up we need to
develop alternative sources of energy
and we're doing it now with ethanol
renewables an energy bill passed the
Senate which is a step in that direction
well tremendous tremendous it is the tax
incentives which have led to a lot of
oil exploration over the years that a
police an allowance and tax breaks and
now we're structuring tax breaks for
ethanol and we are putting requirements
in that electric companies have to have
certain number amount of renewables and
we're putting requirements on automobile
manufacturers to produce cars which give
more miles per gallon so the government
is a tremendous factor